smella rahmanir rahim and hamdulillahi
rabbil aalameen
what salat wa salam o allah rasool e
kareem ala l he was happy he ajma'in
[Arabic recitation]
allah who ate away la sala hain ashhadu
anna muhammadan abduhu wa rasuluh allah
[Arabic recitation]
ajma'in and madad
welcome to our fourth installment in our
reading of zed almighty had a high of a
bet thank you for joining us this
evening shallow - ila we will continue
our journey through this wonderful
illustrious book of Abdullah him one of
his finest works and actually one of the
most important references in all of the
Islamic library with regards to the
sudden traditions and ways in and
biography of the Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wasallam so last
session we were discussing the rule of
the Prophet sallallahu alayhi wa send
him we were discussing how he used to
perform his ablution his wooh boo in
order to prepare himself for prayer now
there are a few things that we are going
to touch on that even opium doesn't and
there are other things that even opium
touches on that we are not going to and
that is because of the nature of the
book again the the book itself is not
written as a book of filk as a book of
jurisprudence rather this book has been
written regarding the way that the
Prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam did
things or said things or perform things
this is what the subject of the book is
when we discuss categorization for
example
in jurisprudence we discuss the
difference between conditions and
pillars and obligations and Sunan etc
these things are not found in this book
really not in that way
they are not categorized in that way and
so we are going to touch on some of
those issues meaning the difference
between something that is a pillar
something that is condition something
that is an obligation of a prayer not
everything that the prophet sallallaahu
alayhi wa salem did and will do is an
obligation likewise not everything that
he did in prayer is an obligation and
what we mean by obligation is that if a
person forgets it or if a person doesn't
do it their prayer is still valid and
this is where we have kind of an
intersection between the Sunnah of the
Prophet sallallahu wasallam and this
type of book and the books of
jurisprudence which make that make that
categorization there's also other things
that have no claim touches on because
obviously the source of this material
for igneel claim is going to be the
books of hadith and the books of hadith
are filled with chains of narration and
chains of narration consists of men and
women that transmit this narration and
so in that if no km discusses the
authenticity of certain narrations as
opposed to others and that is something
that we are not going to touch upon
because that is not something which is
really appropriate to be discussed
outside of the circles of the scholars
and students of hadith we stopped last
session and we are going to pick up
today tonight and show law at the
statement of ignore p.m. Rahim aha la
vaca thali canoodle more Otterbein Mata
well
so even opium rahim allah he discussed
and spoke about how the prophet sala no
idea salem would make will boo we
discussed this we discussed the
description of his woudl now we're going
to discuss other things that are picked
up by looking at all of the narrations
together collectively and so the
scholars of islam have mentioned and in
the correct opinion that the pillars of
we'll do are 6 meaning that in order for
you to have made a valid will do that
will be appropriate for you to then make
salah and any other thing that demands
will do such as the laughs or handling
the most - an individual must perform
the bare minimum of these six pillars of
wooble the first four are the actual
things that we wash or wipe over during
mobile and that is the first pillar is
washing the face part of that is the
nose and the mouth the second pillar of
will do is washing the hands and arms
including the elbows so when allah
subhanahu wa tada says i ll Marivic
what's meant by Illawarra filt is
malmourral
what is meant when allah says and wash
your hands to the elbows what is meant
by to the elbows meaning including the
elbows as if given Cathy avahi Mahalo
mentions in his deficit of surah
al-maida the third pillar is that a
person wipe his head or her head and the
ears are part of the head as we've
established the final pillar of these
four is that a person wash his feet or
her feet completely including
the ankles now even Acharya Mahima hula
he says waka thali callable those are
four pillars he says likewise the
prophet muhammad sallallahu alayhi
wasallam zwibble
was always more a Devin boutot alien it
was always in that order so the order of
performing will do is a pillar of the
order of performing mobile is a pillar
of will do what order we are speaking
about the order that is in the sixth
verse of the fifth chapter of the Quran
surah al-maida Allah Subhanahu WA Ta'ala
says in this verse which we've mentioned
previously ya yo holla Dena Amman either
come to me Allah Salih fell salut - well
idea come in America when Suba Russia
come well Roger alaikum ll cabin he says
that which translates to o you who have
believed if you wish to stand for prayer
then wash your faces
wash your arms including the elbows
meaning your hands all the way up to
your arms including the elbows why wipe
over your heads and wash your feet
including the ankles these four are in
this order and when we look at all the
narrations of the Prophet sallallahu
alayhi wasallam when we look at all of
them and we look at all of the
descriptions of all the his companions
his righteous predecessors his disciples
his students likewise when we look at
all of the nur of these companions that
narrated the description of his will boo
we see that no time authentically was he
ever reported to have made will boo in
any other order meaning starting with
his feet and then going to the face and
then going
the arms or something this this
never happened anytime he would make
will duel consistently any narration we
find of him making mobile or his
companions or them describing his will
duel we see that it is always in this
order this is what if Nilayam rahim
allah says and this is the correct
[Arabic recitation]
one narration in Sun and a bead a wood
and we discussed this in a previous
lecture that the prophet sallallaahu
alayhi wa salem made will do
he started with washing his face and
then his arms and then he wiped over his
head and that he did his mouth and nose
and then wiped it over his head yet this
narration is not an authentic narration
in the correct opinion of the scholars
of hadith so when we look at the verse
in the Quran there is a principle that
we're going to follow and that is
usually it is not always but usually
when a loss of Hanna what Silas starts
with something in the Quran and when he
is mentioning for example certain things
and he mentions them in a particular
order that order is to be retained and
observed if it is an issue of worship so
inside Muslim the Prophet sallallahu
aleyhi wa salem was making hajj in jab
[Arabic recitation]
prophets all alone on the asylum was
making hedge and before his hedge he was
making Alaura he stood on the mountain
of a sufferer because we're supposed to
do a say between Asafa Wilmore WA and so
he stood on that mountain to begin his
say and he said to those around him if
[Arabic recitation]
said to the companions around
begin with what Allah began with meaning
in the Quran and he is referring to the
statement of Allah and Surat al-baqarah
in NASA farewell Marwat m in sha allah
so allah mentions that indeed a sufferer
the mountain of a sufferer and the
mountain of al-marwah they are of the of
the Shire of Allah of the holy sites of
Allah and so the Prophet sallallahu
wasallam
started his say and a suffer just like
Allah started by mentioning a sufferer
so whenever we find something in a
particular order in the Quran usually
unless there is an exception we are
going to maintain that order likewise we
can carry this principle over to the
verse of will do which is the sixth
verse of surah al-maida allah subhanho
wa taala dimensions will do in a
particular order unless we have some
other piece of evidence that would
articulate that this order is not
intentional that this order is not
something that we need to observe then
we go back to the general statement of
the prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam
[Arabic recitation]
he start with what allah started with so
in observing that principle we see that
a love begins with the face then the
arms then wiping over the head and then
the feet that is the order he mentioned
and we have nothing to indicate that
this order is something which is not to
be observed so we begin with what allah
began with and so we observe will do in
that order
likewise when it comes to the sunnah of
the prophet sallallaahu either you will
send them we look at the very vast body
of the sunnah and we see a pattern
and that pattern articulates with
regards to Lulu that the Prophet
[Arabic recitation]
whenever he would make wudu he would
always make will do in that order it
would always be in that order right
and so we take from this that it is an
obligation
it is a pillar why because had it not
been an obligation had it not been a
pillar at least once he would have made
will blue in some other way some other
fashion at least once even if only out
of forgetfulness or to articulate that
this is something that is not obligatory
or binding or for example one of his
companions would have made will do out
of order but this is not something that
occurred so we understand from this that
constant tradition without any change to
that consistency articulates obligation
in the correct opinion right so for
example in salat alfu salat envelop and
salat elisha the dawn prayer the sunset
prayer and the night time prayer in
these three prayers in the first two
raka the imam will recite surat al
fatiha aloud and he will recite some
other part of the Quran aloud audibly so
that those who are praying with him can
hear him now why is it that we do this
well when we look at the Sunnah of the
Prophet SAW alone you asylum we see that
under at no time did he ever pray fudge
Allah or melody Boresha and in these
first two that cannot recite aloud he
always recited aloud so we take from
this that the fact that he consistently
does this
all the time every single time we take
from this that this is the way that it
is supposed to be done right he says as
well that the sixth pillar we're saying
the sixth pillar he mentions them but he
doesn't allude to them directly the
sixth pillar of Lulu is at-tuwani
at-tuwani is quick succession and we
mentioned this last week that when I go
to make boo-boo I have to make that will
boo as a unit altogether in order for it
to be considered valid this is something
that a lot of people misunderstand there
are certain warships that only come in a
in a in a bundle or together right so
for example I just as I cannot take one
prayer and separate it right so I say
well I don't really have a lot of time
now I'm gonna pray one that guy and then
I'm gonna leave the other Veck high for
later so I'm gonna pray one here and
then one there and then one a half hour
later and after all I'll have four of
that guys it can't be separated that way
it has to be all at once as a unit
together likewise is the left circum
circum circle ambulating the kaaba right
making the laughs around the Kaaba which
goes counterclockwise in units of seven
right sometimes people when they go to
Hajj they go to Omaha they make you know
one or two laps and that's it
that cannot be valid in that way bo f is
slow death and the fact that the
least of prayer is to deca right so in
order for the first so that got to be
valid the second Oh Micah has to be
performed in quick succession together
right likewise is the left
in order for those laps in
circumambulating the kaabah they have to
be together in units of seven it's not
been narrated that the prophet
sallallahu aleyhi wa salem would
circumambulate the Kaaba in any less
than seven times at once so that's a
unit right likewise as a say going
between a Safa and Marwah that's a unit
and so so on we say about will do it is
a unit you can't make some of it and
then leave off some for later so let's
say a person says well you know I don't
lifting my feet up into the sink at
home so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to make will do go through all of
these steps of will do and leave my feet
for last when I get to the Masjid they
have better facilities I'll sit down and
make will go there I'll finish up with
my feet alone this cannot be valid
because succession meaning that will be
performed as a unit this is one of the
pillars of and the evidence for this is
a narration on the authority of Khalid
[Arabic recitation]
narration has been collected by an imam
abu dawood assiduous tani in which the
prophet sallallahu alayhi wa salem saw a
man who had a portion on his foot where
the water of lulu had not gotten to it
so imagine you're walking around in the
imagine for example a car that is very
dusty and I pour water all over it
you can see which part even after it
dries which part was washed and which
part has not been washed by the water
because the part that is not been washed
by the water is going to have still that
that sand or that dust on it likewise
these guys are walking around in the
desert and there
travelin or whatever they're doing it's
a dusty environment so when a person
goes to wash his hands or wash his feet
wherever the water has gone on his limb
on his foot you can clearly discern that
this portion of this portion of the foot
has been washed and yet there are other
portions which have not so this man the
profits all alone on you asylum observed
that he had a part of his foot that was
not yet washed the narrator Khalid ib'n
Madden says puddled Elohim which is the
size of a silver coin that he had failed
to wash or that he had missed and his
prayer in his will do and so the
prophets all alone you seldom saw this
man praying and so he commanded him to
go and redo his rule and redo his prayer
right so his will do is not considered
valid now where's the evidence here that
booboo has to be done as a unit and it's
time may expire if it's done if the if
the different parts of the body are not
washed in quick succession it has to be
done as a unit the evidence is that this
man had clearly made will do on every
portion of his body except this one
place the prophet sallallahu alayhi wa
seldom did not say go wash that in one
place no because he had made will do too
long for that the time has expired and
so he commanded him to completely redo
will do from the beginning right so the
scholars of Islam have taken from this
that succession in will ooh is something
which is obligatory it is a pillar of a
boom if no claim on him a whole lot
continues and said well mu he'll be he
Martin Waheeda never has it been
authentically narrated that the prophet
sallallaahu alayhi wa salem failed to
make will do in order or fail to make
will do in
quick succession right and we discussed
this in detail last last lecture he says
well can I ever see Laura's Lahey either
Lamia cooing I fear Hosseini well a Joel
obey me
William Sehun a him I see here or here a
while here or whom away belt in a human
he says and the prophet sallallaahu
alayhi wasalam would wash his feet if he
did not have any Footwear on and he
specifically mentions with regards to
Footwear here he mentions two type of
footwear and that is allah fame which is
a leather sock and a yellow bein which
is the cotton socks this is what a jolt
of is a hoof is a leather sock a gel rub
is a cotton sock if no km we understand
from his words here that if a person has
will do and puts on leather socks or
puts on cotton socks or puts on any
Footwear really that when a person makes
will do they would merely wipe over
these this Footwear and many scholars of
Islam have mentioned that it is only
valid on the hoof only the leather sock
and it is not valid on cotton socks and
many people as well have adopted this
but this is the the correct opinion is
that wiping over the footwear because
their Allah is the same what does that
mean well why is it that a person if he
is wearing something on his feet leather
socks that he would wipe over these
leather socks why why has this been
allowed in Islamic law in Islamic
jurisprudence is it because the person
is wearing leather sock
specifically or is it because it is a
bit of a discomfort and a serious
inconvenience to completely strip the
foot and wash the foot the answer is a
second it's it's a it's it's a pretty
big inconvenience especially if a person
is traveling if they're in a public
place or if they're in a place where
there is not a lot of water or something
of that sort where it's very cold
outside right and so the issue is not
because they are wearing leather it is
not the material of the footwear that
matters rather it is the reason why a
person doesn't have to remove his
Footwear in the first place and so the
material doesn't really matter if it's
made of rubber if it's made of leather
if it's made of it doesn't matter and we
see that some people they even go out of
their way to actively search to find
leather socks specifically so that they
can wear these leather socks and wipe
over them because they feel some kind of
way about wiping over cotton socks and
this is unnecessary if we look at the
type of leather socks that people use
these leather socks are not what the
scholars of jurisprudence of ancient
were even speaking about so the leather
socks that we buy today you can get them
on Islamic websites or in certain
countries they are very soft lambskin
and this is not what the scholars of
Islam we're speaking about this is not
really considered a hoof
anyways a hoof in the Arabic language is
made out of hide and it is a tough hard
leather Anam a machete describes the
type of hoof that they used to have
it is a hoof that when you set it up it
stands on its own right it's not soft
it's a hard leather the scholars
mentioned that this type of hoof that
was worn in the time of the Prophet
sallallahu alayhi wa seldom you have to
be able to walk in it for miles without
it falling apart or having a hole these
leather socks that we have today these
very soft you know they say that they're
made out of lambskin very possibly
synthetic leather what we call pleather
right plastic leather very these things
cannot hold up to walking on them
without any issue this is not what
they're designed for they're just socks
they're fancy socks right the scholars
of Islam when they speak about hole fame
they're speaking about a leather sock
that is hard and it used to take the
place of a shoe a person would either
wear a shoe or they would wear a hoof
and leather sock they would not wear
both because the leather sock is a type
of shoe at that time it's very hard
leather if you stand it up it will stand
on its own and maintain its shape
without the foot being in it and these
don't you know to my knowledge unless in
very remote places don't exist anymore
and so it's important that when we read
that we understand that we're speaking
about things that occurred 1,000 almost
500 years ago that's a long time and a
lot of things have changed since then
right so we have to make sure that we
define things as defined by the scholars
of Islam of that time either way wiping
over your Footwear whether it be socks
shoes whatever it is leather polyester
thin thick
all of that in the correct opinion does
not matter it's all permissible right
let's say a person is wearing a sock
that is very Sheen you can see through
it very very very very thin material a
person does not have to wash his foot
the fact that you can see the skin is
not something that necessitates full
will do why because there it is the same
the reason why we wipe over the sock is
the same and that is the inconvenience
of loss upon Owatonna described this
religion and said well majolica Medina
Maharaj he has not made any burden or
hardship upon you in the religion so the
reason that at the time of the Prophet
sallallahu alayhi wa salem he and his
companions would wipe over these leather
socks if you will those socks is kind of
a kind of a bad translation for a hoof
because of the reasons that we mentioned
is not because they are made out of
leather the material here is immaterial
right the material here is not the point
the point of the ruling is the
inconvenience that this entails if that
is the case then whether the cop the
socks be machine see-through thick thin
whatever the material is as long as they
are socks they cover the majority of the
foot then a person can wipe over them
and they take the same ruling this is
the opinion that if no claim on him
Allah was known for and adopted and also
his ship before him it would say me or
him a whole lot and many others of the
scholars of Islam of ancient and of
contemporary times the point though is
that the prophet sallallaahu alayhi wa
salem would make rule based on the state
that he was in so he would not put
Footwear on to wipe over them nor would
he take Footwear off to wash his feet if
his feet upon
making mobile if he had something on
he'd wipe over them if he didn't he
would just wash his feet he says William
Sehun a he Mara see he and he would wipe
over his ears at the same point or at
the same juncture that he would wipe
over his head waha bakumaru about Lena
Huma inside and out which means the
front and the backs of the ears
he says Wakulla hadith in faith Carroll
will bow and Lotito caruana he faked a
demon ohio tes mia via well ehi Mahal
[Arabic recitation]
abduhu wa rasuluh la imagen amenity will
be no Charlie Meynell Matata hidden
fearfully he he says now with regards to
the earth God of all the earth caravel
now before we get into that we mentioned
the pillars of will do right these are
things that if no claim didn't touch on
in that sense we will the pillars of
will do are 6 if you want to know if
your will do is valid you make sure that
all of these six pillars are present
washing the face entirely including the
nose and mouth washing the arms
including the elbows wiping over the
head including the ears front and back
washing the feet including the ankles
that this be done in quick succession
together as a unit and that this all be
done in this order these are the six
pillars now what about the sunan of abu
those additional things which a person
can do that the prophets will alone on a
human send them did well there are a lot
of things one of them is washing your
hands three times at the beginning
before you start with washing your face
another
is that a person use se wek si wack
meaning that a person brush his teeth
SC wack at the time of the profits all
along line a he was send them is
actually a root of a tree and that is
the tree of an Iraq and it's it's got
some properties to it that helps you
maintain good healthy teeth likewise
when you buy it off the end it becomes
a brush it has almost bristles on
the end this is what the profits all
alone why they he was said I'm used at
his time however a conventional
toothbrush is fine as well that and the
correct opinion does give a person the
reward of brushing his teeth just as he
did in the time as a person using the si
wek right what about a person's finger
well this is an issue that the scholars
of Islam have discussed that we see some
people when they make will do when they
get to the mouth they will put their
finger in the mouth and they will kind
of scrub their teeth and this is
permissible is it the sunnah of the
prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam
that is an issue that has been debated
amongst the scholars of hadith to my
knowledge the narrations regarding him
himself the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alayhi wa sallam himself putting his
finger in will do using the finger in
place of the SI wek to scrub his teeth
whether that be him doing it or him
telling others or encouraging that that
be done they are all weak narrations
some companions were narrated to have
done so
encouraged and so it is acceptable
inshallah
another thing that is part of the Sinan
of Lulu that is encouraged when a person
make will do is that a person say at the
beginning of his or her will do
bismillah some scholars have mentioned
that saying bismillah at the beginning
is actually an obligation however in the
correct opinion it doesn't reach to that
level the reason being that the very
well-known narration now we'll do a
liminal M youth chorus mala he fee
oh I lay there is no rule for the one
who does not mention the name of Allah
upon commencing it is a week narration
however there is a narration in soon and
ethnicity on the authority of NSF and
Matic in which the companions did not
have any water to make Lulu and they
were on a journey this narration was in
Bukhari I'm listening but this
particular part this statement is in
Sunna Nana say that there was no water
and so the prophet sallallaahu alayhi wa
seldom asked who has any amount of water
and so he was brought a small container
that had some water in it and the
prophet sallallahu alayhi wa seldom as
anis narrates then put his hand into the
water this and Anna said I
witnessed the water gushing out from
between his fingers until it began to
overflow and all of his companions that
were with him upon that journey made
will do and when that happened this is
obviously a miracle of the prophets all
along while he was settling when this
happened he said to his companions to
whoa-oh bismillah
he said make will do in the name of
Allah so some of the scholars of Islam
like
whose aim and others they said this is
an encouragement that anytime you go to
make will blue you say bismillah right
and that is correct and it is better for
a person to say it because some scholars
have mentioned that it is an obligation
and it is kind of a lengthy debate that
we don't want to get sidetracked with
likewise another Sunnah of will do is
that a person start with the right side
right to wash the right arm before the
left the white right foot before the
left this is not an obligation if a
person did it the opposite it would be
valid but it would not be the best thing
the best thing is the right first and
then the left another thing which is
something that is encouraged in will do
is washing each limb the mouth nose the
face the everything except for wiping
over the head to do that three times
each and also two times each but the
bare minimum is one time each so there
are a number of things which are
preferred but the things that dictate a
correct will rule and will do that is
valid they have to have these six
pillars there are a number of conditions
as well for Lulu the most important of
which is intention that a person has to
have intention of making mobile well how
can a person make will do without
intention that's the question I mean is
it possible for a human being to do
anything consciously make the choice to
do something without intending to do it
the answer is this is impossible right
however a person could make will do
hypothetically speaking without the
intention of wooble point in case let's
say a person is new to Islam and I say
well come on I'm going to show you how
to make wool so we go to the
place where we make wool and we sit down
together and I demonstrate for him how
to make will do but I didn't have the
intention of making will do
my intention was merely demonstration
yes this is a very rare case in which a
person's will do would not be valid if
they did not have the intention of
making little right he then goes on to
mentioning what a person says before and
after wobble he says every single
narration now this is coming from Abdul
kayum even if no claim rahim allah is
one of the most brightest most
well-informed minds of in the history of
islam with regards to the narrations of
the prophet muhammad sallallahu alayhi
wa send them he says every narration
regarding any kind of remembrance to be
said before or after will do is a
fabrication except for three one at the
beginning of will and two at the end
everything else is not authentic right
so there are some you'll find in some
books and some demonstrations of a
little even online you might find it
that when a person goes to make will
rule when they wash their face they say
you know something oh allah make my
face white on the day of resurrection
when they wash their right arm oh allah
give me my book on my right hand when
they wash the left arm oh allah do not
give me my book of deeds in my left hand
and so on and so forth when they get to
the feet or allah keep my foot
firm upon the set off on the right way
and all of this all of these narrations
are inauthentic they are not just
inauthentic they are fabrications right
the only authentic narrations with
regards to something the prophet
sallallahu alayhi wasallam would say
before or after we do our
three number one bismillah at the
beginning and we just we mentioned that
while ago number two is that a person
[Arabic recitation]
abduhu wa rasuluh elohim agile in a
minute aware being
Rajani mineral mutasa here in i testify
that none is rightfully worshipped but
allah alone and no partners does he have
and I further testified that Muhammad is
His servant and messenger our law make
me of those who are in constant
repentance and make me of those who seek
purification this narration is in sahih
al-bukhari and sahih muslim also it is
found in a sunnah sunnah natira media
Raheem Ajala another narration which is
[Arabic recitation]
establish arakawa atubu alayka that a
person after saying the previous he says
glory be to you our law free from any
imperfection are you and to you belongs
all praise and all that is good I
testify that none is rightfully worship
but you I seek your forgiveness and I
hereby repent to you this is in Sinan
and that's soon and Nessa it's also in
mustard what I can hack him and it is an
authentic narration the Prophet
sallallahu aleyhi wa salem would say
these three things nothing else so at
the beginning of abou bismillah person
concludes with all chadway la la la la
[Arabic recitation]
of IBN majah liminal Matata here in
subhanak Elohim of Abraham Ditka la
[Arabic recitation]
a lake that's it this is the only thing
that has been authentically collected
with regards to what the Prophet
sallallahu aleyhi wa salem would say
before or upon concluding will do he
says well let me a Yahoo lufia well
hehe in a way too
well Adam min a Sahaba Alberta well let
me attach I was a Fed laughs but he says
and furthermore the prophet sallallahu
aleyhi wa salem would never at the
beginning of wu proclaim or verbalize
his intention he would not say i hereby
intend to make Wu never did this happen
there's no narrations of him doing this
nor are there any narrations of his
companions doing this ever he says nor
has it ever been narrated authentically
that he made will do and washed any
particular limb more than three times so
the maximum is three the minimum is one
never did he make more than three right
he says likewise it has not been
authenticated collected it has not been
authentically collected that the Prophet
sallallahu aleyhi wa salem would wash
beyond in making mobile the inclusivity
of the elbows the inclusion of the
elbows and the ankles never did he go
past that so he didn't go all the way up
here right just to include above the
elbows to include the elbows to include
the ankles that's it no further up the
leg no further up the arm Carlo LM EF
Cunha Todd Newton Chifa Allah he and he
was not somebody who would consistently
dry his hands and face off after making
wool duel and of course that is that is
subjective if you're in the summer heat
and you make will do no problem you'll
dry very quickly however if it's
bitterly cold you may want to use a
towel but the prophet sallallahu alayhi
wa said them was only narrated to have
dried off
or shaking the water will do off maybe
once or twice maybe and those narrations
as well have been debated with regards
to their authenticity amongst the
scholars of hadith we will continue
inshallah next week
we thank you all for joining us we ask
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala that he teach
us of his book and of the sunnah of the
prophet sallallahu alayhi wa seldom what
we are ignorant of that he remind us of
his book and the sunnah of his messenger
what we have been made to forget and
that he benefit us and teach us the
wisdom to be derived from those two
sources
subhana Coloma be hamdulillah and estefy
Iruka what to Bullock